i don't think we talked about it but
uh what's soft robotics so we talked
about
like rigid bodies like if we can just
linger on this whole touch
thing um yeah so what's soft robotics
so um i told you that i
really dislike the fact that robots are
afraid of touching the world
all over their body so there's a couple
reasons for that
if you look carefully at all the places
that robots actually do touch the world
they're almost always soft they have
some sort of pad on their fingers or a
rubber
sole on their foot but if you look up
and down the arm
we're just pure aluminum or something
so uh so that makes it hard actually in
fact
hitting the table with your you know
your rigid arm or nearly rigid arm
is a is a has some of the problems that
we talked about
in terms of simulation i think it it
fundamentally changes the mechanics of
contact when you're soft
right you you turn point contacts into
patch contacts which can have torsional
friction
you can have distributed load if i want
to pick up an egg
right if i pick it up with two points
then in order to put enough force to
sustain the weight of the egg i might
have to
put a lot of force to break the egg if i
envelop it with a
with contact all around then i can
distribute my force across the shell of
the egg and
have a better chance of not breaking it
so soft robotics is for me a lot about
changing the mechanics
of contact does it make the problem a
lot harder
um
quite the opposite it changes the
computational problem
i think because of the i think our
world and our mathematics has biased us
towards rigid
i said but it really should make things
better in some ways right
um it's it's a
i think the the the future is unwritten
there um
but the other thing is ultimately sorry
to interrupt but i think ultimately it
will make things simpler
if we embrace the softness of the world
it makes
um it makes things smoother right
so the the result of
small actions is less discontinuous but
it also means
potentially less you know
instantaneously bad
for instance i won't necessarily contact
something and send it flying off
the other aspect of it that just happens
to dovetail really well is that
if soft robotics tends to be a place
where we can embed a lot of sensors to
so if you change your um your hardware
and make it more soft then you can
potentially have a tactile sensor which
is
measuring the deformation um
so there's a team at tri that's working
on
soft hands and uh and you get so much
more information
if you you can put a camera behind the
skin roughly
and and get fantastic tactile
information
which is um it's super important like in
manipulation one of the things that
really
is frustrating is if you work super hard
on your head mounted
on your perception system for your head
mounted cameras and then you've
identified an object you reach down to
touch it and the first the last thing
that happens right before
the most important time you stick your
hand and you're occluding
your head mounted sensors right so in
all the part that really matters
all of your off-board sensors are you
know are occluded
and really if you don't have tactile
information then you're
you're blind in an important way so
it happens that soft robotics and
tactile sensing
tend to go hand in hand
you